we're here to win in and I'll play a lot
better and I think we need a you know
everyone needs to do a better job and I
was not certainly our best effort I give
them a lot of credit they play good you
know they make it tough money on on our
offense their defense and you know we
just could never string enough plays
together
Todd Brady the Patriots quarterback
after the 31 to 20 loss to the Jaguars
in Jacksonville rematch of the AFC
Championship game that was a game that
many think the Jaguars could have
slashed should have won Jalen Ramsey the
jaguars cornerback said earlier in the
offseason that the the jaguars
organization didn't trust blake bortles
the way the players did on sunday they
trusted blake bortles are you cooking up
a song for blake bortles
no we're nowhere you know hey at least
an apology notes well thanks I will say
what what the truth is and he played
phenomenal yesterday there's nothing for
me to say there and I would this this
jumping-off point let's just start with
this conversation this started on Dan
Patrick stay tuned after this show he'll
be on later he asked me about the
Jacksonville Jaguars and I said they are
the best team in football and Blake
bortles is the 70th best quarterback and
that's the issue
now he's played pretty good here early
on this season and that was the best
game he has ever played other than maybe
last year's AFC Championship game I mean
AFC this was better than the AFC
Championship game so I'm not gonna sit
here and take any credit away from him
if Blake bortles hits these throws that
we're seeing right here that are just
you know again I'm not trying to take
anything away from them but this team is
awesome they are gonna win the Super
Bowl they are the best team in the NFL
and if he just takes advantage of the
plays that are there to be had they will
win it I have no doubt about that
Jaguars Chiefs coming up we'll see
really fun to watch and and maybe
they'll be destined to meet again right
in the postseason I just like the idea
of a changing of the guard I hear you
you know and this is nothing against the
Patriots or Patriots fans but you've had
your run right there are other teams out
there it would be nice to see other
teams in the mix it would be nice to see
other teams in the Super Bowl
it just gets it's kind of get a hold
that you I like the Patriots to it's fun
watch them you know kind of be
uncomfortable for a little bit it makes
it interesting about what will happen is
it won't lose another game for the rest
in the other 15 and one and we're on to
Cincinnati we've seen this before when
the Patriots get manhandled and it
happens so rarely it's a big deal yes
right I mean yeah you don't see them
frustrated very often because they win
all the time so I thought they'd win
this one
I thought the Jaguars weren't ready to
ascend past them and now the question is
how did the jaguars build on this as the
hunted they are now the hunted yeah
they're sluggish against the Giants see
last week they were in hunted mode and
they let the jet the Giants hang around
too long they were in the hunter mode
this week against the Patriots now that
pendulum is gonna swing back hard the
other way
every team they face it's going to be
that team is coming after us although
they better be ready for the Titans this
week Reich it's Titans as we get Titan
swept them last yes they did yes but I
do think this is a different football
team and I think with the ability to
trust Blake bortles okay because that's
something they haven't been able to do
this will make them a different team
it's gonna make them a whole lot harder
to defend and and you saw yesterday I
mean it's hard what do you do when you
pie Jacksonville their offensive line
you're hurt if you watch the game I mean
Tony Romo talked about it a little bit
it's one of the best in the sport there
they can physically push back just about
anybody and then with Nathaniel hack
it's great game planning behind it he
does a great job of getting receivers
open and these receivers are dangerous
one on one whether it's killing coal or
Dede Westbrook or Corey grant coming out
of the backfield and then bortles
running which is the best part of his
football game it makes them extremely
hard to defend oh yeah and they also
have one of the best defenses I've ever
seen in my life - so Jacksonville there
you're right they're not gonna sneak up
on anybody anymore but there are a team
on the mission on a mission right now
and I don't know I would say they're the
best team in the sport right now if you
made me power rank football right now I
think after yesterday would you put them
number one I think they're in that
they're close to it I mean them the Rams
the Rams are up there but you know what
what did you say last year about the
Jaguars most talented team
football the only problem is they don't
believe in their quarterback and no one
else believed in the quarterback and now
they believe in their quarterback and
they're letting the quarterback go out
and win and think about what they could
have done in the offseason they could
have moved on from Blake bortles they've
gone after any of the free agent
quarterbacks out there Case Keenum was
available Kirk Cousins was available Sam
Bradford Teddy Bridgewater there was an
unprecedented number of veteran
quarterbacks available and they decided
to stick with Blake bortles they wanted
continuity they think his best football
is in front of him that's a low bar yeah
but there is something to be said for
not changing when you have a guy who you
think is good enough even though they
maybe didn't trust him in the past they
trust him now right we're seeing the
product of it and that was a huge one
that was one of the biggest wins for the
Jaguars in the last 20 years yeah I mean
the biggest wins since but you know back
in the day when Tom Coughlin was
coaching the football winning the
playoff game last year in Pittsburgh I
mean that's big his regular-season wins
go stay and it wasn't quite a statement
game it wasn't 44 nothing but it was
enough a double-digit win over the
Patriots right where you say okay we
have to take this game seriously we have
to take this team seriously we have to
take Blake bortles seriously yeah and
never control in the game throughout and
they had the ball with they were up 24
to 3 and had the ball and DJ shark
fumbled the ball so it wasn't statement
game and of course like you said New
England is still seen as one of the best
teams in the sport and when you show
that you can beat them and frustrate
them not only physically but
schematically that's when you know like
okay we got something good here and
Belichick and Brady they they did not
you know it was not an easy day on them
all right it's an easy day here because
there's so much to talk about when we
return it's time to hand out these
superlatives for week two and over the
next five minutes isn't when Chris will
be doing all of his prep from scratch so
stay tuned to see what he comes done any
yet I've done something professor
you